over the weekend something we've all
been waiting for has
finally been leaked performance
benchmarks for apple's brand new
a14 bionic chip now this is extremely
important for a couple of different
reasons first off
this exact chip is going into the ipad
air 4
and the iphone 12 lineup which are gonna
be released within
the next couple of weeks but the even
bigger deal is that the a14 is being
built on tsmc's
brand new 5 nanometer chip making
process
which is extremely efficient and more
powerful than
ever before and by the way it's the
first 5 nanometer chip
ever made and one thing we know for sure
is that this five nanometer tech
is also going into apple devices like
the future ipad pro
the rumored apple tv refresh and of
course
the very first apple silicon max which
this video is all about
now before i get into what this means
for apple silicon max
i want to go through what apple said
about the a14 chip
when they announced the ipad air 4 and
how that compares
to the recently released leaks apple
mentioned a 40
boost in cpu performance and a 30
improvement
for graphics but what's interesting is
that this is actually compared to the
previous generation ipad air
which had the a12 chip and not the a13
so if we apply that 40 cpu improvement
to the performance of the ipad air 3
we should be getting around 39.65 points
in terms of multi-core performance in
geekbench 5.
now if we take a look at the a14
benchmarks that were leaked by love to
dream on twitter
it actually got a multi-core score of
4198 points
quite a bit higher than what apple is
advertising
so it seems like apple was actually
understating the real performance gain
which is a really good sign now the even
crazier part is that we also got leaks
of the graphics performance
and it's absolutely insane the leaked
benchmarks show a metal score of 12
571 which is actually higher
than the incredibly high performance of
the a12 z chip
in the latest ipad pro now this doesn't
make
any sense at all because apple
themselves
said that the a14 chip in the ipad air 4
is 30
faster than the a12 chip in the ipad air
3.
but it seems like apple was again
completely
understating the true performance this
kind of performance coming from a non
x chip is incredible and if it's true
the future of apple silicon for the mac
is really promising
now one last thing i want to mention
about these leaked benchmarks is the
incredible single core score of 1583
points
that's 256 points higher than the a13
bionic chip
which was already faster than any intel
mac
out there so it's really impressive now
what's great about all of those
performance leaks of the a14
chip is that we can actually use them to
calculate the multi-core performance and
the graphics performance
of the higher end a14x chip
going into the ipad pro and the more
improved apple silicon chips going into
the mac
in 2017 the ipad pro's a10x chip
was around 61 more powerful than the a10
fusion chip
in the iphone 7. and then in 2018
the ipad pro's a12x chip was around
71 more powerful than the a12 bionic
chip
in the iphone 10s so if we assume that
the a14x chip is going to follow the
same pattern
we can take an even more conservative 50
gain just to be safe and apply it to the
leaked a14 performance of
4198 points which basically gives us
a multi-core score of 6297 points
this is an incredibly impressive score
because that's how well the a14x
can perform well inside of a super thin
fanless ipad pro tablet
and it's getting close to the
performance of the 2.3 gigahertz i9
8 core intel cpu that's in the latest 16
inch macbook pro
which is much larger and has an active
air cooling system
now if you think that's crazy it's about
to get
even better going from the a10 chip to
the a10x
the graphics performance more than
doubled and then going from the a12
to the a12x it more than doubled again
so if we take that leaked graphic score
that we saw for the a14 chip and double
it
we get over 25 000 points for geekbench
5's metal graphics test
which is just nuts so if those leaked
benchmarks and estimations
turn out to be true then that means that
the a14x packing ipad pro
is gonna have faster graphics than the
base
16-inch macbook pro with the 5300
m graphics option and if that doesn't
blow your mind
let's get into the apple silicon mac
chips that apple said are going to be a
completely new
family of chips this year most leaks are
pointing to the macbook air and the
13-inch macbook pro
getting apple silicon first and
according to bloomberg
the very first apple silicon max will
get 12 core chips
with eight high performance cores and
four efficiency cores
the current ipad pro's a12 z chip has
eight cores
for high performance and four efficiency
so there's a chance that the a14x
could actually be getting a 12 core chip
matching up to what bloomberg was
reporting
this basically means that the very first
13 inch macbook air
could be getting a chip that's basically
identical to the a14x
but simply rebranded with a different
name to match up to the new family of
chips
but to me it actually seems absolutely
overkill to pack a chip that powerful
into the macbook air since the graphics
performance
would be rivaling the current base
16-inch macbook pro
so i think there's a chance that we
could instead be seeing a rebranded a14
chip from the iphone 12
going into the first apple silicon mac
and then
on the other hand the a14x like chip
with 12 cores
would instead be going into the very
first 13-inch macbook pro
which makes a whole lot more sense to me
and those are just
the very first chips going into the very
first
apple silicon max just imagine what's
going to happen next year
when they release the 16 inch macbook
pro with apple silicon
and then eventually replace the 27-inch
imac
with a new apple silicon model now on
top of all of that
keep in mind that all of apple's custom
hardware accelerators
are included in the apple silicon as
well
like their hvc encoders and decoders
which greatly help
with video editing and then apple also
mentioned that the a14 bionic is packing
apple's new 16 core neural engine
which is now twice as fast as well as
their second generation
machine learning accelerators which are
actually now
10 times faster than before and apple
even showed off the performance
difference we should expect
for machine learning tasks in one of
their wwdc
2020 videos so we're not only going to
be seeing a boost in raw performance
but we're also getting those custom
accelerator chips in apple silicon
as well for the heavy lifting of certain
workflows
and i personally have a feeling that the
performance of the first
apple silicon 13 inch macbook is gonna
be so good
that even x86 apps running under rosetta
2 emulation
are going to be faster than the current
intel chip in the macbook air
can natively run x86 apps so with that
those leaks are showing us that the
future of apple silicon max is
incredibly bright and we're all about to
be blown away
by how well they work as well as saving
battery life
at the same time hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did go
ahead and tap the like button
and click the circle above to subscribe
and be sure to check out our new
zip hoodie right over there or the other
apple silicon video right up there
whatever it is
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video